tomorrow I get ready for a parade of
divas taking over the American Music
Awards and earlier today I was with
returning host Tracee Ellis Ross in a
fabulous hot pink who's ready to bring
the heat and bring hot pink honey on it
on a Monday more in a sparkly shoes I
mean that's how you start a date tell me
about the fashion how many outfits how
many fittings I think it might be a
baker's dozen
last year was 11 you know it'll be fun
cuz we love the clowns
besides the fashion what else is Tracy's
super excited for are you ready for it
for starters this girl who is opening
the show Taylor gut I mean come on I
call them the three seats
you ready party Mariah Carey Carrie
Carrie Underwood sorry and Irwin and now
we just saw her in rehearsals with a
little baby bottle
that's why I came back guys just so I
could have a front-row seats the best
concert JLo's performing - she's got a
front row seat right next to a rod and
then t-swift wonder if she'll bring Joe
I'll win as her date there will be a
tribute to Aretha Franklin but what's
the story behind the blackish star doing
this for the hundredth episode we are
doing a prince tribute and we got access
to his library we all get a moment to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]